watch it right now so the king uh has
thoughts okay Cadets I want y'all to get
ready
iron Lords podcast
fatigue gear is in session now
sit down
and let's assess what just happened
the opposition has just full barred
themselves that's right you heard me
right fubard themselves we have seen a
terrible show we were preparing for the
worse and what we got we got absolutely
nothing it was a white drizzle
so I want everyone to hold the line and
prepare
for June oh June can't come too soon
pause
so remember people hold the line and do
not football yourself so like the
opposition did that was absolutely
disgusting he thought Spider-Man could
save the day I say no way
did you see what happened when the
opposition tried to do games of the
service
smelled like poo absolute poo so all you
spineless jellyfish that left their
ranks stay where you are enjoy that you
are fubar
[Laughter]
B
well
how'd you like that show
it's definitely fantastic now
I know a lot of guys is out there
complaining but come on man I gave you
Spider-Man Don't You Buck up on me do
not buck up on me
I gave you some games of a service I
showed you some trailers you got Bubble
Bobble too the remix
fantastic stuff
and um from what everybody says IGN told
us it was a near perfect show
IBM is on program
everybody needs to be on program if
you're not on program I need you to go
to our brainwashing camps so you can see
exactly what I want you to see now I
want you to see a perfect 10. and I want
you to know and love Spider-Man and uh I
showed you a handheld now I don't want
nobody complaining about the battery
life you're home
when it dies plug it back in and get
back in the game an hour later
three four hours you shouldn't be gaming
that hard anyway we know that y'all need
your Twitter time
so I made sure that was three to four
hours in intensive games
so you can get back to Twitter playing
Twitter like you like the most
and I'm gonna tell you we making big
bucks here you guys pre-order Spider-Man
at an alarming rate you guys I
appreciate every last one of you stay
brainwashed and I heard the opposition
telling people to hold the line well I'm
gonna tell you to hold the LIE hold the
LIE alive
Don't You Buck up on me Don't You Buck
up on me
so uh yeah
uh yeah King made his presence uh no
obviously he has his thoughts in his
opinions and we gotta get into the rest
of this battle but yeah definitely hold
Hotel oh the PlayStation dudes you're
not supposed to hold the line you're
supposed to hold the line salute the
king for always glad he has to know how
he's he called the second one
that's the butt character that's the
reason yeah the rich Tycoon PlayStation
owner who doesn't care about Gamers
feelings so to speak anyway
moving on we got some steam guests let's
get right into it addicts topic but I'll
set it up for him so yeah obviously the
PlayStation showcase aftermath we've had
time to assess and I want to actually
start off with bad bit because I haven't
talked to him in a while yeah that's a
bad [__]
some Trophy Room assessment right quick
you know now they have time to settle
you know what are your thoughts on the
PlayStation showcase man it's been a
crazy few days of just me kind of coming
to grips with what I saw because on one
hand you know I said this on the trophy
room this week if it was if the show was
a Jeff Keeley joint this was a great
show there's like a lot of games that
I'm interested to play like you know
alawick 2 looks fantastic right like
Assassin's Creed looks phenomenal can't
wait to play both of those but when it
comes down to how do I feel as a
PlayStation show I can't help but feel
like this
this felt like an obligation to Partners
rather than them wanting to put out a a
good show like there was a lot of third
party representation again a lot of
games I'm really really into but when it
comes to the question I feel like we all
had walking into this event which is
what's after Spider-Man we still walk
out of this going what's after
Spider-Man right like fair games the
logo side seems interesting I hate that
I have to read it through a blog post I
would have loved to hear like Jade or
someone on that team like talk about
what this game is because when you hear
it or read it it sounds interesting I
have no idea what Concord is Hell divers
okay looks like a fun time but other
than that like
what is PlayStation's 2024 looking like
and is it them having to rely on
third-party Partners or second party
Partners to to push it through I I don't
know so as a as a fan I can't help being
let down by a 600 plus weight of what's
the next PlayStation thing to get
excited for so to me I just felt like as
a PlayStation show this was like the
second best state of play I've ever seen
right like I feel like the state of play
in September was fantastic like rise
around and where was that game Stellar
blade where is that game amazing game
right and so to me I'm just left as a
PlayStation fan disappointed as a gamer
who's going to be probably playing all
these games that they showed I thought
it was a great showcase but again not a
not a PlayStation one so at the end of
the day I can't help but be kind of let
down okay so just really quickly if
we're doing one to ten yeah scale like
what would you give it currently
as a showcase itself of games that I'm
interested in a seven if I'm thinking
about this as a PlayStation showcase uh
thing that's supposed to represent the
the future one plus two years of of
PlayStation
I mean I saw that that Spider-Man stuff
and I loved it and if you all know me
I'm very biased when it goes to
Spiderman I give it about like uh I know
right I give it about like a five or six
on the PlayStation front uh nowaday's
divorced from it so again good showcase
is not a good PlayStation one okay no
fan about here where you coming from all
right let's get the Viper let's get
Cobra Commander himself got stuck in a
little secret but I don't know if his uh
thoughts have changed since then so now
that you had a couple more days to
settle like what's your thoughts on the
PlayStation showcase right now yeah well
it was fine well I guess it's not even
fun it just is what it is like the
advantage of doing a show like ours
where we don't do live streams I'm no
longer in media so I don't have to write
anything is that we kind of just get to
react and then we get to back off right
right and uh it's actually one of the
reasons I don't really I'm not really on
Twitter anymore I just promote things so
I know people don't really tweet at me
very much anymore but I notice a lot of
people were tweeting at me so I clicked
on it that's when people were asking me
to be on the show so we we talk to each
other via text and and I was happy to do
that but I actually got to kind of just
assess it in a vacuum I sat on my
recliner my fiance was next to me we
watched it on TV I was taking notes we
were going to go right in the sacred
symbols afterwards and I was a little
surprised by how negative people were
about it and the more I think about it
the more it really encapsulates it's
like what happened to redfall kind of
okay like is redfall the worst game of
all time I highly doubt that no you know
um and I just feel like everything's
either the best or the worst right like
you either want it to be all for you or
you can't really see any perspective of
what the company was trying to do so as
I actually agree in that for me I'm I
kind of play Strange games right like I
like my Shooters I like my first party
games and all that but I play a lot of
turn-based games a lot of role-playing
games a lot of Japanese games there
really wasn't anything there for me
whatsoever
um but in like kind of a vacuum when I
was watching and I'm like oh I bet you
the audience is going to be pretty
stoked that we see what Haven's working
on I bet you the audience is gonna be
pretty stoked that we see what fireworks
working on uh Etc and so on and so when
I go on to artist Discord or I go into
patreon and then we're recording so I'm
going on and then as we're going I'm
going on Playstation blog right and I'm
looking up things I'm like all right so
what is this PVP going to the comments
everyone hates everything right yeah go
to the Discord everyone hates everything
go to the Twitter feed everyone hates
everything and I'm like I don't think it
was that bad like it wasn't great I
think you can argue it wasn't even good
depending on your perspective but I do
think that there's like a space between
you know I I feel like I wanted to say
this because I feel like this was part
of the strategy and I don't know but
maybe you guys can tell me if you think
I'm onto something let's go they
released a 38-page document for their
fiscal year 2022 so Sony split into six
sections as I'm sure a lot of people
know PlayStation is one of those silos
yep it's called games and Network
Services they released a 38-page
document on this and here's what they
said and I mean they said a lot of
things but there's just certain things
where in fiscal year 19 12 of their game
of their revenue or I'm sorry 12 of
their investment was in games as a
service fiscal year 23 so the one we're
in now 55 of their investment will be in
games as a service fiscal year 25 so
that's two years from now 60 of their
investment will be in games as a service
Investments by new IP versus old IP in
fiscal year 19 only one in five dollars
that Sony spent on development was spent
on new IP that's Now 50 50 and moving
upwards and so what I say by that is I
look at it I'm like I kind of see what
they I think they were trying to do or
what they thought that they were trying
to do certainly as I said earlier there
are a lot of third-party things in here
and Deals foam Stars looks amazing
rip-off I can't even believe it
is Splatoon
Nintendo's lawyers will be at the ready
that particular game made me want to
talk about Square Enix much more than I
even want to talk about Sony because you
would wonder how much of a glutton for
punishment this company can possibly be
making games and service whether it's
babylon's you know publishing babylon's
fall Avengers outriders which I love
outriders was arguably my game of the
year when it came out I [__] love
that game
um great but it's I it's so that was
weird but I think overall it was fine
you know and I I wrote down some stats
that I thought were interesting 34 games
in 70 minutes certainly big complaints
were lots of lots of CG yeah not a lot
of gameplay I think the biggest problem
was the spite of a lack of a Spider-Man
date although my my kind of 20 I kind of
broke the news on it Colin he said it
starts in August the marking for that oh
yeah yeah yeah and I believe and I and I
my personal theory on this is that
they're gonna bundle it with the new
PlayStation and you know the news model
and they don't know when that's going to
be ready I also think that uh they don't
want to kind of there's so much velocity
in the old sales right now I think
they're kind of afraid so I think they
were in between a rock and a hard place
it would have been cool he got a date
for hell divers too but I personally see
I went to fair games and I'm going on
and on I'm sorry but I wanted
tube
um and people hated it right like
everyone hates that game I'm like I
don't it definitely has that Ubisoft
stench yeah which is makes sense because
it's a Ubisoft game essentially that
team is basically a Ubisoft team
um Concord we don't really know what
that is 75
anything about it they literally just
showed like the thing in the burger I
was like what is this about yeah so so
for me okay so for me it's like but then
I went to Spider-Man I know Spider-Man
was brought up earlier Spider-Man 2 and
actually pushed Square just wrote about
this and I went and looked
between so on Playstation they have 7.5
million views on that trailer already
with 374 000 thumbs up and 9 000 thumbs
down 9.2 million on Marbles YouTube
channel 388 000 thumbs up 7.6 000 thumbs
down Phantom Blade was a huge thing too
1.7 million views 84 000 thumbs up 1.6
000. so like when people say it's like
that was the [__] oh I'm sorry that
was the worst thing ever sorry about
that that was the worst thing ever I'm
like I don't know about that I've been
in the industry for a long time I can
there were worse E3 conferences than
that they were worth it I don't know so
I just feel like it's somewhere probably
in the middle okay I've heard from
people that I know and I think it's
fairly obvious that there will be
another showcase later in the year I
assume it will be
um
more focused on some of these games that
are rattling around but like a future
game showcase like they branded it the
first time around yeah something like
something like this and maybe just even
Market it as first and they don't like
using the term second party they just
like to pretend everything is first
party but really like mature and get
those games out of there but there are a
lot of things that I was reading into it
where I just I'm like where is the room
for the middle when I was watching this
I'm like I just don't see it this way my
audience really sees it this way it
seems like the hardcore PlayStation
audience really sees its way but as I
kick it back to you guys I ask you
what's this going to change nothing Well
PlayStation 5 is still gonna sell
enormous amounts of units Spider-Man 2
is still gonna sell 10 million copies in
a few days like all these so it's like
to me it's just it's very a small
blemish
what I will push back on Colin and I
want to ask you this is that what about
the fact that the weight right we've had
the the two years so to speak and the
fact that there hasn't been you know
it's been pretty we have state of
plagues things like that but the fact
that there really hasn't been any
significant and then obviously see the
moniker of showcase and historically
PlayStation let's be clear like they
have put on Amazing showcase like to the
like the Showcase of Dreams grown men
crying announcements of games that you
couldn't eat when they're in person it
was it was a very interesting thing yeah
so but I also remind people of that too
that last E3 it was pretty bad but it's
just like the standard has been set so
high right so do you internalize that as
us the gamer putting too much pressure
or based on what we're used to them or
just hey that it was okay but you know
it wasn't as bad as people say but I
think the the main a lot of the main
discourse I'm saying is that people
waited for so long and they felt
disappointed in conjunction with not
only that a lot of CGI no actual
gameplay no action release dates first
party game that actually had gameplay
right so I think it's a combination of
the those things but I'm curious to see
specifically about the two years my
question for you is really about the you
know being that they've been away for a
while and then come back if you see
maybe you can understand on that side
why the the base is so kind of like
virally upset with I definitely
understand that dude trust me there's
you know
I I kind of never fall under the
hardcore PlayStation Camp of what people
feel for instance I thought God of War
was great but I didn't think it was like
the best thing I've ever played I
thought Horizon was way better than
you've been kind of War personally right
I'm always in like kind of a weird space
right I've been in the PlayStation space
for a long time but I'm not quite Your
Mark where it's like you can be like
this is the guy right that plays
everything and does everything I'm like
I don't know about that I have kind of a
weird taste so I I do try to take that
into account which is why I try to look
at things more objectively I think I
look at things from Sony's perspective
and I don't they probably are a little
surprised in fact I think that they
definitely are surprised by the feedback
I've talked to some people at the very
Studios
um you know I congratulated some of my
friends at Insomniac for Spider-Man 2
which looks absolutely I mean insane
amazing that the presence of that game
alone I think makes it can't possibly be
bad and especially when it's 70 minutes
long and so it's like that's literally
one seventh of what they showed
um so I don't know it I I think Sony I
think the Sony's perspective right now
and I think this is why the Activision
dealer like why they're so engaged in it
is that according to the documents I was
reading they only plan on releasing two
first party games a year that's what it
looks like they say that straight up
that's all they want to do they say at
least two first party games a year so
that's two first party games a year so
when you look at things it's like okay
they don't really want to have this
release schedule I think they're much
more frankly focused on getting like
honkai rail star or whatever the hell
that game is called that gun should
impact thing over to PlayStation where
they make hand over fist money on it
over and over and over again it's the
same reason why they're so concerned
about Activision leaving so I think they
just look at it and they say like people
are gonna freak out they have a right to
freak out you're absolutely right from a
hardcore PlayStation fan dude I want to
know what all these guys are working on
too I want them to talk I heard some
interesting rumors and things it was
cool to see helldivers and Arrowhead
re-emerge after eight years and all
those kinds of things but at the same
time I I just think we have to explore
the middle ground and it really does
remind me of what Xbox just recently
went through with redfall where it's
like dude it's I just looking at it it's
not the worst game of all time like
there's no way that the way you're
talking about this is actually realistic
for what the game actually is whether
people like it on so this Falls
somewhere in the middle I think yeah you
know and I I just think based on the
data I was telling you people have to
get used to PlayStation saying this kind
of stuff they are interested in being in
this space save that thought yeah next
time because I got some very good
question to ask you that time but I saw
a jump in and I want to open it up yeah
I I think I think that's where it is
like there has to be room for the middle
ground it's right like we cannot we
cannot go at Sony for for the stuff that
we've been seeing Microsoft do forever
right where it's like you know game pass
that you have a lot of those smaller
games on Game Pass they do make their
way into big showcases in ways that I
personally don't necessarily like but I
do think it is something that you that
you said in the past as well Colin I
think it kind of holds true on the
PlayStation side but for different
reasons where you say Game Pass is
taught Xbox players not to buy games
right and I think the expectation on the
PlayStation side has kind of taught some
of the PlayStation base right maybe
perhaps the loudest ones in the
PlayStation base that
anything that doesn't look like a
horizon that doesn't look like a god of
war anything that doesn't look like a
Last of Us is inferior and that you know
being that that has been kind of the
company company line all the way from
the PS4 it's kind of it's difficult for
them to sort of
except that this is a new reality I
absolutely think this is a new reality I
was just surprised that they didn't make
an attempt to hide it as much as I
thought they would with you know
interspersing more of these sort of
um you know PVP games and and service
games with their bigger titles
um so I for me it's just it's it's a
narrative thing and how true that is and
how true you know narratives are are
created and die every single day but at
the end of the day it just feels like
the narrative that a PlayStation
hardcore player that loves what
PlayStation became in the PS4 generation
this is completely opposite to that yeah
and and there's that fear that this is
what they are moving forward and I think
it's more than a fear like you said it's
the truth and we're gonna see more and
more of it they're telling you trickle
this way they're telling you I just sort
of think I just sort of think that
it's weird because in the past we've
accused Jim Ryan of saying things that
weren't true or whatever or not
understanding the business just caring
about the business side of it and not
you know the faith that you have to put
the fans and whatever but he it's funny
because he has sort of been on that line
where he knows the he knows the the pop
that the big bangers get and here it
sort of seems like they went into this
and didn't read the room and realized
that too much of this without the
bangers around it was gonna get this
reaction and uh I mean in a way I I
can't say I kind of commend them because
they sort of jumped in feet first and
kind of they're telling you what it is
and they're telling you're going to see
more of this